emmanuel ercis direction juridique de li
na li na est fondée sur le droit puisque
c'est la loi qui nous a créés c'est par
la volonté du législateur qui a eu ses
missions confiées à l'ina de
conservation d'une part et
d'exploitation d'autre part lorsqu'on
vend une archive
en fait on vend tout ce qui est les
frais liés à toute la conservation la
protection des supports mais on vend
aussi des droits en vend un droit de
producteurs un droit d'auteur est un
droit d'artiste interprète chaque
exploitation donnant lieu à une
rémunération c'est une licence de droit
à chaque fois qu'un client ou même que
lina veut exploiter une archive en fait
tout ça s'inscrit dans un cadre
juridique le client va donc sélectionné
son archive elle va passer dans
différents systèmes d'information à
l'ina dont le système d'information
adage qui est le système de
capitalisation juridique qui va
permettre aux juristes d'analysé en
fonction du périmètre souhaité par
l'utilisateur final de lui donner les
droits disponibles
éventuellement les droits pour lesquels
il faudra une action de libération afin
qu'on puisse l'autoriser ou non
disponibles en fonction de ce périmètre
chaque juriste va analyser les extraits
où les intégrales qui lui sont demandées
au regard de la documentation juridique
contenues dans les dossiers de
production qui sont numérisés maintenant
depuis une dizaine d'années les nouveaux
usages fond qui est des acteurs nouveaux
qui sont intervenus voire même des
particuliers notamment avec le
développement de tout ce qui est plate
forme type youtube où les gens se
sentaient tous réalisateur et prenez des
archives
voilà sur le net on à un exercice
pédagogique à faire assez fort par
rapport à ces personnes là puisque il
faut leur expliquer les fondements
juridiques que les résonances les
impacts que ça peut avoir une chaîne
youtube peut être tout à fait fermée sur
une question de droit d'auteur donc
c'est un nouveau public d'utilisateurs
qui contournent en fait enfin qu'ils ne
savent pas c'est pas par volonté de
piratage c'est vraiment par
méconnaissance de l'environnement
juridique qui doit être respecté en fait